kabloosh Reta yama in the Makarov
sahibul Mandela Alabama Alabama
بطل هاكاتا لـ Dillon ماذا لو
أخبره Kodava أننا لم نكن قادرين على
الوالدين في الوقت الحالي لأننا فقدنا
دخلنا لذلك لم يكن سعيدًا بالقول
على الأقل لم تفعل  لم تصرخ بفعل
أي شيء ، لقد كان مستاء للغاية
لفيدل وياماتو فيلم Elahi laelia
بفظاعة ربو التل صورة demova
ماما يمكنني استخدامي الآن الطعام هو
المصاريف المهمة الوحيدة التي يمكنني التفكير
فيها الآن
phanie York و Amaya أحمق
كبير  يارموث ياهو لحن لانا ها
الصاروخ على بيت لحم
Elfie hovel ballad mundo الربو تهامة
تقارب Samaritan watt a معينة
melinda Bob Dole Maliki Tov ajamu Nevada
Metal Mario Salerno Olivia Metallica
heretical Pharaoh Cleaner لأن الكثير
منهم فقد وظائفهم وكان
الكثير منهم يكافح  كان من
الممكن أن يأتي الكثير منهم ولكنهم أصبحوا
بلا مأوى ، لذا أخبرهم جميعًا بالاسترخاء في
المنزل والتأكد من أنهم يساعدون
جيرانهم زملائهم في الغرفة لديهم طعام
على مائدتهم la Cañada Libya al-Maliki
New York Eliza في Meza Mario FAL من كينيما تيسارو
أنا مرتاح ، أكون أكثر سعادة ، لذا
من يعيش فيه بشكل خاص ، يتعين علينا
صيانة هذه المباني ، يتعين علينا دفع
ضرائب الممتلكات على أساس شهري ، يتعين علينا
دفع أقساط الرهن العقاري ، وعلينا
دفع تكاليف المياه والصرف الصحي التي تمر
عبر السقف ، لذلك كل شيء  هذه النفقات لا
تزال حقيقية ، فهم لا يزالون
هناك على أساس شهري ،
تمثال Amma Maha Valois Dyatlov O'Malley Cuomo لرجال نيويورك Mojave لقد كانوا
فكرة رمزية أطلقها مائة من
الطاقة الذرية الساخنة في المنطقة أنا أقصد  نأمل أن
يكون التل ESMA